yo
guys had a change to a warner brothers
related beanie
because i was just on uh scn
live uh for schmod entertainment network
while we were there
this news broke in the middle of the
stream and then we spent
like 35 minutes chit-chatting about it
it's a really
it's a really fun stream by the way you
guys should go over there watch that
video i'm telling you
it's a it's a really really fun time all
right
you get like my reaction to the news
right there and then there's some great
opinions going back and forth about this
but if you guys haven't heard yet and
haven't had a chance to talk with john
about it warner brothers
in regards to hbo max they're going to
be releasing a crap ton of movies
a whole bunch of movies this coming
year of course we know about wonder
woman 84 of course we know about the
snyder cut
but jon why don't you read aloud the
movies they have
said and i actually didn't believe this
at first if you go to that stream i was
like no this can't be real
yeah but then warner brothers put out a
trailer showing no they're doing this
for real this is really happening read
it away all right this list is
circulated to multiple places so i'm
confident in it
the little things which is denzel
washington's new movie judas and the
black messiah
tom and jerry godzilla vs king kong
mortal kombat those who wish me dead
the conjuring the devil made me do it in
the heights
space jam a new legacy reminiscence the
suicide
squad malignant dune the many saints of
newark
king richard cry macho and the matrix
iv this all of this crazy this will all
come out on hbo and in
any theaters that exist at the time yeah
yeah
i don't want to even though i was joking
about like when i was on the stream
about
just taking everyone's opinions that
they're over there i do encourage you
guys to go check it out i'm still so
confused on exactly how the business
model works
this shift makes sense to me of course
i'd rather i want to see more than 50
of these movies in the theaters where we
live there's no theaters open within
60 miles you don't want to watch the
matrix
for your home tv like this shift makes
sense
it's a great way to compete in the
streaming wars undoubtedly
undoubtedly it's gonna i don't even
think hbo max is completely worldwide
yet so
by the time they are worldwide this is
going to change the game
entirely i could just imagine how many
more theaters are going to be going out
of
business um over the next year
especially because these are some huge
juggernaut
i mean matrix for the suicide squad what
i noticed is
the batman isn't on there so
maybe there's a chance there's one i bet
they're holding on to it
we're gonna play this one so by here
this is supposed to be just for 2021
though
yeah they said this is a one-year plan
as of now just because they assume that
yeah
theaters will be operating if at all
yeah low capacities and so they're going
to test this out
that's where i was kind of going back
and forth with some people on the stream
of my argument against like i don't
quite get
how the profit margin really works for
hbo max they've apparently gotten rid of
their free trial you you sign up 15
a month you get more people to pay 15 a
month does the profit of how many
they're
expecting to get monthly for all these
moving announcements
will that equate to how much they were
expecting
to make off of these movies being
released in the theaters
that's where some of my confusion comes
in because they're like well they're
playing the long-term game but in the
long-term game this is only going to be
for one year so what if people decide to
unsubscribe after they're done with the
movies you know i don't know if that'll
be the case or not if like
the suicide squad the only place you
could watch it is
on hbo max in my opinion though i mean
like
i'm excited for it because it gives me
access to all the movies i have hbo max
and so in terms of like an audience
standpoint i'm definitely excited about
it i guess like the model of streaming
just confuses me because i've been
hearing like netflix is like completely
bankrupt for the longest time
or you know it's or not bankrupt but in
major debt and they still keep releasing
new content so i'm like is this gonna
put
them in financial debt i mean we win but
do they win
like that's where i'm kind of confused
on some of this yeah i don't know i mean
i've heard
that about netflix for a long time and
part of that i've heard is because they
spend so much producing like everything
they just green light tons of stuff and
they have a pretty good rep for not
meddling too hard with purple's
creativity which is a double-edged sword
so i've always been curious about how
they thrive and i feel like right now
they're doing fine because you know
theaters for them are like the
afterthought that they had to fight
against right
right extra legitimacy but yeah with hbo
max
i would be curious because now i mean
you know you got more people at home i
wonder how all these apps are
faring against cable because you know
for certain people you just get hvo max
through your cable subscription and so
like that's not gonna generate more
profit off these movies i wouldn't
imagine unless they create an extra
paywall which doesn't seem like
it went too well when disney tried it i
can imagine that this would entice a lot
of people and this does seem like the
edge
a lot of regular folks might need to be
like oh dang that's something special
about hbo's streaming service
which i thought was already a thing from
hbo go and hbo now
you know so this does seem like a good
plan to at least keep people around for
that year
i don't know after that i mean it it
seems like a smart move to at least
embrace the circumstances of right now
and
see how this goes because the thing is
too if they get you know into
march april may and they're like oh man
this is not going well they can totally
change the plan
but right now i think you know even just
having this big slate
announced is enough to get people
mumbling because you have
so many different opportunities in this
list to play to different audiences
but what christian was telling me on the
stream is that the stocks went
up once this announcement happened so
this would actually be bad publicity if
they decided to move against this
i know yeah i can see that especially i
mean and what's also
fascinating to me is how they're going
to make a lot of money on hbo max moving
forward
but they're going to be releasing these
movies in select theaters
about how netflix will sometimes do
limited release but they do it like very
limited
when netflix would do that when theaters
were a normal piece of the business
right is there even a point to them
putting it in theaters now if they're
gonna put it in certain select theaters
like how how many people are really
gonna be like
unless you're just a hardcore movie buff
yeah you know if we if we had access to
that
we would absolutely go yeah but
i feel like the average moviegoer is
just going to be like no just watching
hbo max
why do i have to go to the theater to
what unless it's something that
really calls for it but even then i feel
like the average moviegoer worldwide
people who are not movie buffs
they're not really going to give two
shits about whether or not they have to
go to the theater so i'm like well
actually
where they stand to lose money is in
those select theaters they're releasing
any of these movies you know yeah and i
mean i guess part of me wonders if
that's
them just trying to keep that spark
alive i know in the statement
uh the hbo rep said like we want theater
experience as much as anybody like
that's what we
want and i wonder too if they probably
are able to
triangulate where these profits are
coming from so maybe they'll run them in
places more prone to like
cinephiles who want to go out like maybe
they can look at how tenet did and go
okay these territories were okay with
the turnout at least for what the
capacities would allow
so we'll at least release them there i
mean that's exactly what i brought up
though was about christopher nolan
like how is christopher nolan feeling to
this news
he's done all his movies with warner
bros at least like most of his most of
his movies he's done with warner
brothers
i imagine that the concerns and the fact
that he's kind of
spoken about some of his frustrations
with how warner brothers was reviewing
the success or the numbers generated
from tenet yeah it seemed like he had
some criticisms towards the way warner
brothers
was reflecting on that on the results
and on the information
so i can imagine a scenario where nolan
ultimately decides to leave
warner brothers because i don't know
it's like is he
is it part of the tenets ex like lack of
success because that's the way it was at
least circulating in the news you know
they weren't
i kind of agree with nolan in the sense
of they didn't look at how
with what the world that we're living in
now how well tenant actually did
considering all that yeah they didn't
look at it that way they just wanted to
bring things back to normal
but my point is is because of the way
tenet was perceived as
a not a success at the box office is
this the reason why all this is
happening now cause that's a giant
freaking oh before it was just part of
it wonder woman it's an undercut there
you go
now it's all the movies except for
batman but the thing
to me at least is i feel like wonder
woman was the big because snyder cut is
like okay this is a fan generation
we're going back we're tweaking
something that pre-existed whereas
wonder woman is like a gigantic it's a
holiday season draw so that to me was
yeah the damn that
hailed this like i was almost more
surprised about that than i am about
this now
because you know with the way things are
looking it's kind of the only option
they have unless they just want to
pile up movies for years i just didn't
think it would be this many movies
it's like i think there was so many
movies
i didn't think they would go the full
year i thought they would maybe go a
quarter or something and be like we're
gonna start out with this trial run of
these
four or five highly anticipated
tentpoles that we have ready to go
especially it's like i get that you want
to like put some big ones on there in
order to attract people but i'm like god
damn some of these are major movie
like could have been juggernauts if they
waited you know godzilla versus kong
suicide squad space jam people
yeah that's the only one people are like
we're boycotting hbo mexico
um watch that one i'll probably do like
record streams out of all these though
like just watch and netflix just raised
their price i was annoyed yesterday
because they weren't taking my card
information so we could review on our
hunter
but now like netflix razor price hvo max
is only i think a dollar
more for what i pay for hbo max i mean i
think netflix is only a dollar or less
of what i currently pay for hbo max for
right now
hbo max seems like they're offering a
little bit more movies that i'm
a lot more interested in than what
netflix has to offer now they just gotta
get their tv show game up and then we're
good to go
all right guys are you excited about
this news leave your thoughts down below
subscribe
click that notification bell hit the
like button please do leave your
thoughts
and also uh check out under my
appearance on sc live i'm telling you
like it turns from a really fun
discussion and then
once this news breaks it becomes a very
fascinating discussion
see you guys